das hier ist ein Euro und werden dann
für 1 € von ein paar Jahren noch ein
Cheeseburger bekommen hat zeigt man
heute das Doppelte deshalb habe ich mir
die Frage gestellt was kann man noch
Essen für 1 € was wirklich lecker ist
und man keine Abstriche macht und ich
glaube eine Sache steht fest wir müssen
selbst Hand anlegen wir kochen heute
drei Gerichte für 1 € Los geht's kommen
wir zu den Zutaten für unser erstes
Gericht eine Sache vorab wir werden nur
den Anteil berechnen den wir auch
tatsächlich benutzen das heißt wenn wir
eine große Packung kaufen nur ein
bisschen was benutzen dann berechnen wir
auch nur das Wissen ihr könnt ja
parallel schon mal überlegen was es gibt
hier sind die Zutaten Mehl Wasser
gehackte Tomaten Hefe Oregano Basilikum
Olivenöl und Knoblauch acht Zutaten die
insgesamt 77 Cent kosten das heißt wir
haben sogar noch ein bisschen Geld übrig
am Ende und das obwohl die Sache die wir
kochen besser gesagt Backen wirklich
brutal ist denn wir machen Pizza und
nicht irgendeine Pizza Pizza Marinade
die Ursprungs Pizza das heißt wie
Mozzarella nur ohne Käse könnte man ein
bisschen traurig bezeichnen aber viele
Italiener schon darauf und ich glaube
auch wirklich dass sie richtig gut wird
das wird übrigens eine richtig große
Pizza die wir hier machen deshalb satt
sollte ich auf jeden Fall werden ich
gebe hier mein Mehl in die Schüssel dazu
das Salz und vermenge das ganze schon
mal ein bisschen wenn das erledigt ist
gebe ich in mein lauwarmes Wasser
frische Hefe wir brauchen nur fünf Gramm
rein damit und wir lösen die Hefe einmal
ein bisschen auf wenn unsere Hefe
aufgelöst und aktiviert ist können wir
sie einfach zu Mehl und Salz geben wir
verkneten das jetzt einmal zu einem
homogenen Teig danach müssen wir nur
noch ruhen lassen ich hol ihn jetzt raus
und auf unserem Block Punkt Shop Brett
können wir dann noch mal ein bisschen
durchkneten dass ich die glutenstruktur
bildet ist ja nicht mehr so stark klebt
Ende machen wir eine schöne kleine Kugel
raus hier muss man ein bisschen Arbeit
reinstecken aber wenn man kein Geld
reinstecken will muss man es halt selbst
machen der teigrohling ist fertig in
kleiner kleiner Spritzer Olivenöl rein
und streichen damit es uns nicht anklebt
dann können wir ihn auch schon
hineingeben und mit einem feuchten Tuch
abdecken weil Klarsichtfolie würde Geld
kosten es wird Zeit unsere Pizza fertig
zu stellen ich habe hier drüben schon
meinen Ofen benutzt einfach was für euch
am besten passt wenn ihr einen
Pizzastein habt benutzt den wenn ihr
einen Pizza Stahl habt dann benutzt das
ich benutze das weil ich habe es dafür
gekauft aber wir backen die sowieso
nicht in der politikanische deshalb
funktioniert die Pizza auch im Haus dazu
das sind fein gehackte Tomaten ungefähr
eine halbe Dose die werde ich einfach
noch ein bisschen zerquetschen mit
meinen Fingern das ist die Technik von
Francesco Yala so den besten Pizzabäcker
der Welt der Kerne drin enthalten und
wenn wir die Verletzten dann wird bitter
und das wollen wir natürlich nicht auch
wenn wir für unter einem Euro Pizza Salz
an mehr braucht man eigentlich nicht für
eine gute Tomatensoße auf einer Pizza
gute Tomaten bisschen Salz wenn man
möchte noch ein bisschen
Geschmack ein bisschen pusten sollten
tue ich was rein schneiden unsere
Knoblauchzehe in Scheibchen relativ fein
so dass wir sie einfach am Ende
drüberlegen können kümmern wir uns um
den Teig unsere Frischhaltefolie freie
Konstruktion hat es ihm ermöglicht
wunderschön aufzugehen ich habe meine
Hand ein bisschen nass gemacht und jetzt
wird es spannend ich nehme ihn nämlich
einfach so wie er ist frei in ihn aus
der Schüssel das Olivenöl auf jeden Fall
wichtig
wird er rauskommen das klebt schon ein
bisschen dicker ja
und ich lege ihn aus so das ist ein
richtiger Oschi Alter darauf kann man so
eine Big Pizza machen so eine richtig
fette wir geben oben und toppen bisschen
Mehl wir fangen an dem wir von Norden
nach Süden den Rand formen wow also er
hat richtig schön Luft aufgenommen ist
extrem fluffig der Teig und es ist
wirklich genug Teig für eine ganze
Familie habe ich das Gefühl
das mache ich auch schon mal den Ofen an
kannst mal vorne rein gucken vom
Durchmesser her können Sie die
klassischen 32 cm sein die man so vom
Lieferservice auch bekommt nehmen wir
jetzt die Soße die wir vorbereitet haben
und verteilen Sie auf unserer Pizza
jetzt
jetzt auch hier drauf soll sie gar nicht
erst anpacken ich komme jetzt außen rum
Bewegung Bewegung Bewegung und wir
droppen nein jetzt wird's langsam dunkel
hinten das heißt einmal beherzt eingehen
ja schön einmal von unten gucken was
sehen wir da auf jeden Fall die brauchen
wir nämlich auch weil von oben dauert es
auch relativ klein finden wir jetzt
unsere Pizza marinara oh die sieht
wirklich gut aus schön angetrocknet das
ganze mit ein bisschen Olivenöl als
kleiner Spice Kick oder na ja Spice ist
das nicht aber es ist ein bisschen
aufregler mit unserem Knoblauch bisschen
oregan nur noch mal drüber das ist nicht
ganz so langweilig aussieht ich glaube
das wird was nicht zu vergessen unser
Basilikum aber gucken dass man den Boden
an bisschen Farbe dran bekommen ein
bisschen tigerung jetzt kommt die Frage
schmeckt diese Pizza für so wenig Geld
wir schneiden uns ein schönes Stück raus
das Öl oben drauf ist wie ein
Knoblauchöl geworden die Pizza verneigt
sich bisschen Crunch im Rand auch hier
sieht man schön fluffig geworden das ist
wirklich so eine fluffige Pizza nicht so
eine super dünne aber gucken wie sie
schmeckt
das ist wirklich unfair uns fühlt sich
an als würde ich was illegales machen
was ich so etwas Leckeres mit so wenig
Geld erschaffen habe der Teig ist
wirklich fluffig die Tomatensoße
obendrauf hat so eine leichte Säure ein
bisschen mehr als man vielleicht von
Sana sano Tomaten kennt aber zusammen
ergibt das dieses italienische etwas was
wirklich in seiner DNA einfach sehr sehr
italienisch schmeckt knusprig fluffig
günstig 77 Cent dafür das beste was man
für unter einem Euro machen kann crazy
wirklich ultra lecker
Freunde probiert das hier ist eine Pizza
für 77 Cent boah hat mich das gekostet
dass du Backen Pizza marinara irgendwie
traurig aus Deutschlands das schmeckt
die umso besser
das ist echt heftig was sagst du
da
für unser zweites Gericht unter 1 €
benötigen wir folgende Zutaten einmal
Zwiebel Frühlingszwiebel Knoblauch Reis
am besten alten Reis zwei Eier Sojasoße
und Öl und unser Gericht ist gebratener
Reis mit Eier klingt erstmal
unspektakulär ist aber glaube ich
ziemlich ziemlich lecker und damit
reizen wir auch ziemlich knapp das
Budget aus 96 Cent und ein paar Zutaten
sind überraschend teuer z.B kostet eine
ganze Zwiebel wir arbeiten extra nur mit
einer halben 20 Cent im Vergleich zu 18
für die Frühlingszwiebel auf jeden Fall
ordentlich wir schnibbeln erstmal ein
bisschen weil dann geht's richtig
schnell wir machen unsere Wokpfanne heiß
und geben unser Öl hinein hier kann man
natürlich wenn man mit die Budget nicht
limitiert ist noch ein bisschen mehr
rein machen aber wir arbeiten mit dem
was wir haben ich schneide auch schon
mal unsere Frühlingszwiebeln einfach in
feine Ringe im Prinzip brauchen wir gar
nicht so viel aber die ist so günstig
und gibt uns so viel Farbe Kontrast und
so dass wir es einfach mal mitnehmen ich
denke das Öl ist mittlerweile auch gut
heiß geworden
[Musik]
von der Frühlingszwiebel habe ich auch
noch ein paar Abschnitte drin und wie
das halt so ist in dem Wok ne können wir
auch richtig mit Hitze Arbeiten zack
Knoblauch dazu ja und als nächstes dazu
ein bisschen weniger als ein Tag als wir
vorhin gekocht am besten ist es dann am
Tag alt ist so dass die Körner dann
quasi auseinander fallen ja das ist auf
jeden Fall eine ordentlich Portion ne
also wir können uns sogar den Luxus hier
gleich zwei Eier noch dazu zu geben
einfach weil es das Budget hergegeben
hat jetzt gebe ich einen Teil unserer
Frühlingszwiebel dazu gehört das schon
Knistern wir sind auf einem guten Weg
wir kriegen noch ein bisschen Farbe an
den Reis so muss es sein das ist
übrigens die allerhöchste Stufe auf der
ich gerade arbeite also wir brauchen die
Hitze hier schlage ich meine Eier rein
die direkt ein bisschen kochen wenn Sie
ein bisschen gestockt sind mische ich
den Reis dazu Sojasoße dran deshalb
brauchen wir auch kein Salz oder
irgendwas wir müssen sehr schöne
Konsistenz erreicht jetzt gebe ich das
Ganze einmal hier eine Schüssel rein
nicht viel aus aber genau das ist
richtig viel das ist eine ordentliche
Portion
wow
wir toppen das ganze mit
Frühlingszwiebeln bei uns auch die paar
letzten Tropfen Sojasauce noch mal on
top das wirklich alles benutzt ist
97 Cent können so gut aussehen 100 Gramm
Rohre Reis zwei Eier das ist auf jeden
Fall wirklich eine Speise die Substanz
hat wahrscheinlich das ausgeglichenste
was wir heute kochen kann eigentlich gut
schmecken
sehr sehr gut dazu wenn man noch Barsche
hat prispy chicken oder Tofu worauf man
Lust hat dann ist das wirklich ein
brutales Mehl das ist wirklich ein
Gericht wo man wenn man es einfach nur
so essen würde ohne jegliche
Hintergrundinformation dass wir hier
sparen wollten sie sagt Paris lecker
wenn ich gerade eure Aufmerksamkeit habe
Leute ganz ganz ganz bald kommt da was
bei Block deshalb schaut mal auf der
Webseite vorbei tragt euch in den
Newsletter ein oder geht auf Instagram
wird heiß langsam genauso wie unsere
nächste Speise da gibt's ausnahmsweise
mal nichts herzhaftes sie bereiten wir
jetzt zu kommen wir zum letzten Gericht
das kann entweder im Frühstück sein oder
ein Dessert wir machen Blätterteig
Apfeltaschen ich finde wenn man
Blätterteig hört würde man niemals
denken dass der wirklich günstig im
Einkauf zu haben ist und neben
Blätterteig benötigen wir noch Apfel
Honig und ein Ei das ist alles was wir
brauchen auf tik tok gehen diese
Blätterteig Rezepte gerade ein bisschen
viral und ich zeige euch wie ich dieses
hier mache wir nehmen uns einen Apfel
falls ihr so günstig ist du kannst ein
Kilogramm Äpfel für 1 € im Discounter
kaufen das sind dann halt nicht immer
richtig hübsche aber der jetzt zum
Beispiel ist einwandfrei um ehrlich zu
sein reicht uns sogar der halbe Apfel
die andere Hälfte kann man einfach so
snacken ist quasi noch die cherry on top
wir schneiden jetzt feine Slices aus
unserem Apfel raus nehmen wir uns ein
bisschen Honig und streichen ihn aus
auch Backpapier da ziehen wir darauf
unsere Apfelstückchen brauchen wirklich
nicht so super viele ich hätte auch
niemals gedacht dass das so sehr laut
gesehen habe Honig ist auch nicht
günstig aber durch runter rechnen geht
das auf jeden Fall klar der kamelisiert
schön der Apfel gibt seine Feuchtigkeit
in den Teig ab das wird crazy die legen
den Teig jetzt einmal oben drüber und
decken so gesehen unsere apfelscheibchen
zu bedrücken das außen ein bisschen an
mit einer Gabel geht auch schöner sage
ich jetzt einfach mal ne
geht's nicht kommentiert gerne mal aus
kommt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben
geht es noch schöner ich kann nicht
jetzt ein Ei wie cracket verquirlen
Pinsel jetzt den Blätterteig von oben
damit er diese goldgelbe Farbe erhält
und ich glaube wenn man das dann am Ende
rauskommt ist schon fast unfair die
günstiger das eigentlich ist und wir
gehen rein und bepinseln das ganze
großzügig jetzt nehmen wir das Ganze und
geben es bei 200 Grad in den Backofen
ist das Golden braun
mach's gut werde hübscher wenn du
rauskommst werfen wir einen Blick auf
unsere Blätterteig beides wow
wunderschöne Farbe und jetzt müssen wir
gucken wie sie von unten geboren sind
weil die Magie passiert wenn wir das
ganze jetzt flippen die vorsichtig mit
meinem scraper drunter wow
ihr seht womit wir arbeiten die Äpfel
guck mal hier sind richtig schön weich
geworden der Honig Duft schlägt mir noch
entgegen und ich glaube wir haben einen
richtig richtig nice erstmal auf einen
schönen Teller dann sieht das direkt
ganz anders aus 91 Cent für dieses
Gebäck das wirklich einfacher nicht sein
könnte ich muss sagen Leute das hat mich
überzeugt also der Zubereitungsprozess
hat mich überzeugt wenn es jetzt auch
noch gut schmeckt dann brauchen wir gar
nicht weiter reden ich probiere direkt
noch schön warm
Brunch ist real
Tablet auch einfach pur perfekt Essen
dieses Boot Träger da ist auch ein
bisschen Salz sogar drin
unglaublich gut genauso wie die anderen
Rezepte also es muss wirklich nicht
immer teuer sein Okay Freunde ich hoffe
die Gerichte haben euch gefallen ich
finde das ist das Beste was man kochen
konnte für 1 € bitte ich mein teilweise
sind wir sogar drunter geblieben ich
muss sagen ich bin extrem lecker satt
geworden vielleicht könntet ihr ja
Inspiration schöpfen schreibt mal in die
Kommentare ob ihr das ganze mit zwei
fünf und so weiter denn wir könnten in
jeder Budget Klasse die besten Rezepte
für das Geld raussuchen mach's gut danke
fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten Mal ciao